[Music]
Iron Man 3 yeah what about it it is
awesome yeah yeah wait that movie's not
even out yet notice it's out today no I
mean today in the sense that we're
launching this video today yes it comes
up today but ok we're filming it today
it's not yet it isn't Europe and I think
I would know it if you'd gone to Europe
to see Iron Man 3 why because that could
have noticed your absence and it would
have been glorious not if I did it
sneakily covertly covertly in shifts
included Europe and shoots I'm not
saying I did no I'm just offering that
as one possible explanation for haunted
have gotten to Europe to see Iron Man 3
we're not you know there are other
possible explanations how many different
possibilities are there how many
different ways could you have got a user
I coulda teleported over like those guys
in jumper Oh see now I don't know why I
didn't think of that I could have used a
Star Trek transporter right because
those are really gonna use standoffs
personal eagle taxi service now you
really need to let the Eagle thing die
don't you think maybe I'm a ninja
honestly the 13-hour flight to Europe
done and shifts over multiple evenings
is deathless started self possible
regardless the point is I've seen Iron
Man 3 and you haven't and it's awesome
prove it prove that I've seen it yeah
man if I say anything proof worthy I'm
gonna be spoiling the movie's plot for
all our nice viewers don't kid yourself
man not that many people watch these
things not the conversation at least the
people who are watching it seem to be
enjoying they're just humoring you I
have to be nice because they think
you're mentally challenged you're
mentally challenged can't use that as an
insolent and it's basically the same
thing is calling me retarded no no it's
the opposite of that that phrase
mentally challenged was created so that
I could call you slow without any of the
shame that comes
use the word retard Wow dude dude wait a
minute I saw your sins videos for
Ironman 1 & 2 why would you even see
number 3 I thought you hate it - first -
what's up with that why would you even
goes because I do a sins video about a
movie doesn't mean I hate it ok but man
I thought you got this by now since
video isn't it record of a movies
quality overall it's just a freaking
list of sins but what the some of the
things you say are just jokes honoring
man I must have missed the part booth
and got to determine the rules for how I
define sins so soon is anything that you
find wrong in the movie or any dickhead
observational jokes you wanna make I do
not endorse that definition of cinema
since not many minutes are enough in
fact definition of a cinema sin is a
closely guarded secret how there's only
three people in the world but know the
original recipe for Colonel Sanders
chicken okay
yeah those are the three people I would
tell what the definition of the seniors
because they know how to keep a good
secret
it's couldn't done that effect your
honor so why does it have to be a secret
why does it have to be publicly I can't
you just watch a video that pokes fun at
a movie when I'm acting like I've
violated one of your constitutional
right violate my constitutional right my
right not to be confronted by internet
assholes shoving their opinion in my
rights right because YouTube videos are
so true civ and invasive dude can you at
least tell me why you've lead this way
alerts you
[Music]